The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: Welcome
back to 6.890.
Today will be our last lecture
about pure 3SAT, so to speak,
and we'll be focusing
in particular on circuit
SAT today.
But before we get started
with more reductions,
I want to highlight two styles
of 3SAT proofs that we've seen.
This is orthogonal to
the circuit perspective
versus logic perspective.
And I think it's interesting
to highlight the two
different approaches.
So approach one I'm going
to call dual rail logic.
These are not the usual names.
We're making up names here.
There aren't really names for
these types of reductions.
And the other type I'm
going to call binary logic.
These names come from actual
circuit stuff, real hardware.
So for example, all the
Nintendo proofs we saw
are in the style of what
I would call dual rail
logic because the
variables have two outputs.
And the idea is that
this one is activated
when x is set to true.
This one is activated
when not x is set to true
or x is set to false.
Never should both of
them be activated.
So you have a separate
rail, separate line
for the true case,
and a separate line
for the false case.
And this is usually called the
variable gadget that does that.
And I'm going to make up
some more terminology.
I'll call this semi-wires
to distinguish from wires.
So over here in the
binary logic case,
this is sort of a
half of a distinction.
It's a semi-distinction.
This is my attempt to
unify things slightly.
So the idea is that these
semi-wires, either they
get activated, or they
don't get activated at all.
In the unactivated case,
nothing happens to them.
So they're not
really interesting.
In the binary logic
case, the idea
is that the wire gadget is
active in all situations,
but it can be active
in two different ways.
You can either set
it to the true state
or you can set it
to the false state,
and it represents both
sort of in one wire.
Now, this distinction is going
to get a little bit of egg.
But we saw an example
of this kind of proof
when we were talking
about crease pattern,
flat foldability,
and p hardness.
The wire was the
pleat, and the pleat
could be folded one
way or the other.
But either way, the
information is right here,
and the same wire gets
put into this gadget
whether you're true or false.
Whereas over here you're
connecting to this clause
only the true half wire or
semi-wire goes to this clause.
The false one goes to this
clause and to this clause.
So there's a
distinction between here
where the wire's
been split in half,
and here where it's
all in one place,
and the wire goes to the gadget
whether it's a true or false.
I think that's what
I wanted to say.
My main intent here is to
highlight what kind of gadgets
you need.
So we have a wire
gadget on this side,
a variable gadget on this side.
For binary logic you also need
a splitter or a split gadget
to make copies of the wire.
So the idea is you
have one wire coming
in, there's some magic
split gadget which
makes two wires or three
wires, whatever, coming out.
So then you can repeat
split however many times
that variable occurs.
You can make a copy.
In the non-monotone
versions of 3SAT
you may also need a
negation or not gadget.
If you need negation, then
you'll need a negation gadget.
In some cases you also
need a terminator gadget
in this perspective.
A terminator gadget is just the
end of a wire, you might say.
So if you want to
just not use a wire,
then you would put
a terminator gadget.
And the idea of the terminator
gadget is it leaves it free,
leaves the wire free to
choose true or false.
Now, sometimes you can get away
without a terminator gadget.
For example, if each
of your variables
occurs exactly four times, then
you can just use two splitters,
make four copies, and
then connect those
directly to the clauses,
maybe with some negations.
So in that case, you
wouldn't need a terminator.
Over here we're
using a terminator
in a certain sense, which
is the edge of the paper.
If a wire goes to the edge
of the paper it becomes free.
So that's sort of the
terminator gadget here.
Though we didn't
make explicit, it
was part of this overall plan.
In both cases, in one
and two, you probably
need something
like a turn gadget
and maybe a crossover gadget.
We've seen these
in various forms.
In this case, the turn
gadget was very explicit.
I mean it was also a
splitter and also in negator,
but in particular,
it changed the angle,
and we needed that in order
to take this truth value
and send it up to clause
and aim everything right.
And in general,
if you were doing
any kind of embedding
into two dimensions,
you're probably
going to need a turn
gadget so you can move your
wires or semi-wires around.
A lot of the time people
might call this also a wire,
so that's why.
But I think it's
useful to have a word
to distinguish these kinds
of wires which are only
active or inactive, versus
the wires which are always
active but in two
possible states.
Hopefully that clarifies or
makes more explicit the types
of proofs we've seen so far.
Now, today we're going to
do a couple of circuit SAT
proofs, which all of this
applies to circuit SAT proofs,
as well as SAT and 1
and 3SAT and that'll
equals SAT, that'll equal 3SAT.
Circuit SAT you're
going to have-- I
guess in principle you
could do it dual rail
logic or binary logic,
although usually we
probably think of them in
this capacity in binary logic.
And you're going to have wires.
You still need
splits because you
need to be able to take
the output of a gate
and send it to
multiple other gates.
In addition to a
not gadget, you're
going to want some other
universal logic gate.
So we're going to talk
about that in a bit
after we see some examples.
Our first example is
called Akari or Light Up.
This is another Nikoli puzzle
like Sudoku and Numberlink
we saw last time.
So here's a sample input
and a sample output.
Ignore the black dots there.
So you're given a grid.
There's blank
squares and there's
obstacle squares where you're
not allowed to put anything.
Some of the obstacle squares may
have a number between 0 and 4
on them.
And that number represents how
many, among the four neighbors,
edge neighbors of that
square, how many of them
should have a light?
These blue circles are lights.
OK, so like this one has zero
lights in those four positions,
this one has two, this one has
four, that's forced, and so on.
A lot of the cells are free,
but whether you're lit or not.
And then the rules
are so you can
think of a light
as a rook in chess,
so it can see everything
horizontally in the same row,
up to obstacles, and in the
same column up to obstacles.
So this guy, for example, lights
this portion and this portion.
This guy lights that portion,
and the thing here, and so on.
And the goal is, first of all,
to light the entire board,
so that's why it's all green,
it's all lit in that way.
And no two lights should like
each other, because then it's
too bright I guess.
I don't know.
So no two rooks can
attack each other
would be another perspective.
I think those are the rules.
So you've got to satisfy
the number constraint.
You can only place lights
in the blank squares.
You have to light everything,
and they can't see each other.
So this is a valid solution.
This is puzzle one on
the Nikoli website,
and there's a ton more
if you want to play.
AUDIENCE: So you're
saying they can't
be in the same NOR column?
PROFESSOR: I mean they
can be in the same column,
but they have to be
separated by an obstacle.
So they can't see each other
within a sort of sub-column
or within a sub-row as
given by the obstacles.
Cool.
So that's the
problem, and now we're
going to prove that
it's NP-complete.
This is the nice proof
because it's relatively simple
and it illustrates a kind
of circuit SAT and style
reduction.
So for starters, and I
would say most SAT proofs,
a good starting point
is a wire gadget.
You want to think about can
I make some construction that
has ideally exactly
two solutions, one
to represent true, one
to represent false.
So here are a variety
of ways to do wires.
And this is a fairly
flexible kind of game.
The basic one looks like this.
Most of things are going to be
obstacles to tie it down, make
it easy to separate gadgets.
But here we have two
blanks squares, a one,
two blank squares, a
one, two blank squares.
That's sort of a
simple kind of wire
because you know from this one,
either x or x prime is a light.
Exactly one of them is.
So that forces alternation.
Done.
Why?
Because if we choose x, we can't
choose x prime because then
they're in the same sub-row
and all the way down the chain.
So in general, if
x is true, the idea
is that the x's are the lights.
If x is false, then the
x primes are the lights.
Now, that's a basic wire.
But part of the wires
we need a turn gadget.
So this is a 90 degree turn.
Just check that
this is still lit.
If these guys could not see each
other, I think this is black.
It's also OK.
The alternation's
forced by the one.
But some flexibility.
And let's see.
The other fun thing you could
do is spread out the x and x
prime.
If you put a bunch
of zeroes here
to force that there's
no lights here,
because this has to be
lit again, one of these
has to be active, and the
ones force an alternation.
So this is helpful because if
our wires just look like this,
and this will come
up again today,
then you're forced to be
congruent to zero mod three.
First your width has
to be a multiple of 3.
And this can be an issue.
If you have a bunch of gadgets
each of the different sizes--
maybe one is 5 by
5, another 3 by 3,
and other fun
prime numbers, then
you might have trouble
actually getting gadgets
to meet edge on.
Maybe there's a
gap of one or two
or something
between the gadgets.
But if you have a
set up where you
can adjust the wire lengths to
be any integer, that's good.
You can do this
most of the time,
but then when you're
getting close to the gate,
if you're off by
one or two or three,
you just make it a little bit
longer and you're all set.
AUDIENCE: The unfilled
one can also just
have a crossover gadget then?
PROFESSOR: Ah, sorry?
AUDIENCE: Since
you have nothing--
it's very natural to have a
crossover gadget by putting
two of them orthongonal.
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah.
You can make a crossover
gadget easy in this set up.
I think that is a future slide.
So we'll do crossover in a bit.
Let's start with-- yeah, you
can very easily do crossover.
We won't need a crossover here.
That's what I mean.
So we definitely need
splitting, though.
In general, whenever
you have wires
you've got to be
able to make copies,
because if your variable
only appears in two places,
3SAT is easy, our circuit
SAT is probably easy.
So here is a splitter.
This is the main mechanism.
I guess these ones and this two.
So these ones force
an alternation
between here and here.
These have to be
opposites of each other.
And then the two-- so if
both of the x's are present,
if this is absent,
then these two
have to be present by the ones.
And so by this two,
that's all there is,
and therefore this is absent.
So these guys have
to be the same.
These guys have to be opposite.
And conversely, if this
is present by these ones,
these have to be
absent, and by this two,
this has to be present.
So this is almost
sort of a-- well,
you could also
put some ones here
I guess if you felt like it.
Anyway, if you think
about the parity
here, when we're represent a
signal coming into a gadget,
there's x on the left
and x prime on the right.
So that means coming out here
there's not x prime on the left
and x on the right, so this
actually a negated copy of x.
And up here with some turns,
we have a regular copy
of x and a regular copy of x.
This is actually a fairly
common thing that happens.
When you try to split maybe
you also get a negated copy,
or instead you get
a negated copy.
This is actually
great because it
kills two birds with one stone.
You could use this
as a splitter.
It kind of makes 3D
copies of your signal.
But you could also use it
just as a negation gadget, as
a not gate.
I think I have a slide
of those done explicitly.
Yeah.
So here we're effectively
using a terminator gadget.
We're saying, well, we could
throw away this negated copy
because we already have
two positive copies
and that's enough
for a splitter.
So if we just end this wire
here, great, we've got a split.
Or if we throw away the
two copies of x and we just
want the negated copy of x,
then ends up looking like this.
So we get a split
gadget and a not gate
essentially for
free out of this.
You could just
present this gadget
and say, oh, I also
have terminators,
and then you know
that you get these.
But for fun, he drew them
and I'll show you them.
I won't show you them
in future proofs.
Cool.
So let's see, what do we have?
We've got a wire.
We've got a split.
We've got a not.
We've got a terminator.
We need some kind of clause
or some kind of logic gate.
And then possibly we
also need a crossover.
We have turns.
Next up is a gate.
It's sort of a mega gate.
I'm guessing McPhail tried
various little configurations
and then found one that
did interesting things.
It actually does two
interesting things at once.
So we have x coming in on
the left and y coming in
on the right, so both of
them have this x prime and y
prime, then negated copies.
And then we've got
some fun stuff in here.
So let's start with
maybe the bottom,
which is supposed to
be an OR of x and y.
So let's say that they are
both false, for example.
And in general, we're going to
have to check all the cases,
but I won't do all of them.
So let's say this is absent.
This is absent, meaning the
it's lit from the other end.
AUDIENCE: If it's false it
means that x prime is present.
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh, right.
Sorry.
If they're both false-- I
though it was good-- then
both of these are present,
and therefore, we're
going to get hopefully
that this one's absent
because the OR of false
and false is false.
So the claim would
be that A prime and B
prime must be activated.
AUDIENCE: If they
weren't then you
couldn't light both A and B.
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
These are at best OR'd together.
At most, one of
these is present.
These regions both
need to be lit.
So we're going to need
at least one of them
to be on, but once
one of them is on,
we know that z is absent, and
then the other one must be on.
Right, this too.
Good.
And then we should
up here get x NOR.
So when these were
both false and present,
these were present,
these are absent,
and therefore, this is present.
And the x OR of zero
and zero is zero.
The x NOR is 1, so that's good.
So in general, you
check all the cases
and confirm this is the case.
Again, by putting terminators on
here, we can get either x OR y,
or x NOR-- x NOR
y-- it sounds funny.
That's great.
This is the one that
we really care about.
The OR gate-- well, so
different answers to this.
But you should know, and we'll
talk more about this later,
NAND-- or let's say
NAND gate is universal.
And a NOR gate by
itself is universal.
They're just good
things you should know.
They go back at least 50 years.
AUDIENCE: What does
universal mean?
ERIK DEMAINE: So universal
means that from those--
if you're just given
a bunch of NANDs,
then you can construct
any logical get you want.
I will talk about
that more in a moment.
So this OR is
particularly interesting
because we already have
NOT, and so from OR and NOT
we can make NOR-- it's
just the NOT of the OR.
And so from that, we should
be able to make anything.
Which is great,
except for one thing
which is the crossover gadget.
So in the case of Light
Up, crossover gadget
is easy to construct.
But because we have
x OR anyway, we
can use this fun fact that--
this is the symbol for x OR.
If you have x OR gadgets, you
can make a crossover gadget
for free.
So this communicates
x to x, y to y.
There's four cases.
I won't check all of them.
But that's cool
because we have x NOR,
we can negate it and get x OR.
And then we can take three of
them, plugging them together,
and we get a rather
complicated crossover gadget
if I expanded it out.
There is a simpler one, but
we don't care about simplicity
here.
These are just constants, and
we just care about polynomial.
So that's Light
Up as empty heart.
AUDIENCE: Do we need
crossover gadgets
in general for circuit SAT?
Is planner circuit SAT hard?
ERIK DEMAINE: Please wait.
Yeah.
This is something-- well, yeah.
I want to talk about that
after the next example.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ERIK DEMAINE: Which we'll get
to an answer to that question.
Which as far as I know hasn't
been explicitly raised before,
but the answer is basically, you
don't need crossover gadgets,
and for all the
cases I can think.
So that was Light Up is NP hard.
It's also in NP because a
certificate is just where do
you put the lights.
There's only polynomial
number of places to put them,
and checking it is easy.
Cool.
So NP-complete.
Oh, here's for fun an
overall construction,
which McPhail worked out.
So putting all the pieces
together and possibly using-- I
think here there's
maybe no crossovers.
So in general, with Circuit
SAT you can construct sort
of any Boolean formula
you want once you
have a universal set of gates.
But yeah, you can work
through details here.
It's easy to convert
between AND and OR
just by negating the
inputs by De Morgan.
So you've got x OR y is NOT
x and NOT y or vice versa.
So as long as
you've got NOT an OR
you can construct AND and
vice versa by negating things
appropriately.
So that's what he's doing here
for getting some ORs and so on.
And because there's
two copies of x-- well,
x is sort of getting split here.
I guess you didn't
have to split x.
You could just connect directly.
This is a pretty nice
clean construction.
It could actually make decent
resize puzzles with it.
AUDIENCE: So you end up with
the wire carrying the formula
just by doing all
these combinations?
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
AUDIENCE: And then
what do you do?
ERIK DEMAINE: Ah, good point.
Thank you.
There was one more point to this
picture, which is this zero.
This should be an OR of x
false, and this OR or this AND
and blah, blah, blah,
which is this thing.
AUDIENCE: So if that
wire's carrying true,
then you don't need to put
a light next to the zero,
otherwise you would
have to, and that means
the puzzle can't be solved.
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
So for this puzzle
to be solvable,
we better not put
a light here, which
means it has to be here, which
corresponds to this formula
being true, I think, if
I got that parity right.
Or either way.
You could put a one there and
force there to be a light.
So this makes the puzzle
feasible if and only
if this formula's feasible.
Because the wires
are unconstrained,
except by setting this
thing equal to one.
So this is a special kind of
terminator, you might say.
A true terminator.
You want to force the thing
to be true in the end.
That's usually
pretty easy to do.
Terminator's usually one
of the simplest gadgets
to worry about.
But yeah, you do need it.
For circuit SAT you
need-- let's add that.
Circuit SAT you need let's
say a true terminator.
There are other ways
you could do it.
Cool.
Other questions about Akari?
All right.
So our next topic
is Mine Sweeper.
This is from our poster.
We did Super Mario
Brothers, and Bruce Lee
did Rush Hour, so Mine Sweeper's
the last one on the poster.
Let's prove it hard.
We're actually going to cover
two proofs about Mine Sweeper,
because there are sort of
two natural problems you
might ask about it.
The first problem
is consistency.
So this is I give
you a set up, I'm
going to give you a partially
solved board that you're not
given the x levels.
So just a regular
instance of Mine Sweeper.
Maybe you're told where
some of the bombs are.
It won't actually matter,
because all the bombs that I'll
draw here are
drivable from this--
I should mention the
rules of Mine Sweeper
just in case you haven't played.
Anyone not played Mine Sweeper?
I'm not willing to admit it.
The numbers here representing,
among all your vertex
neighbors, all eight neighbors,
how many of them are bombs.
You don't want to click on the
bombs because then you die.
So your goal is from
this partial information,
these blank squares
represent zeros.
From this partial
information, you
want to figure out
where the bombs must be.
And here's a very
familiar looking wire.
We can't just have obstacles
that are wild cards.
So we have to put
numbers if we don't
want there to be bombs there.
That makes the gadgets quite
a bit trickier to work with.
But this looks pretty similar.
We've got these ones,
which force an alternation.
Exactly one of these two is
a bomb, so if x is present,
x prime is absent
and vice versa.
And then this one forces--
I guess actually this one
forces these to be opposite.
So that forces the
alternation down the line.
So again, there are exactly
two solutions to this wire
gadget for where
the bombs could be.
And so the Mine Sweeper
consistency problem
is I give you some picture
involving these things,
and I want to know is
there a solution-- is there
a placement of the
bombs that satisfies
all of these constraints?
Now, you might ask why is that
the problem we care about?
And one reason if you're
playing Mine Sweeper,
you'd like to know, for
example, could there
be a bomb at this position?
So could there be a
bomb at this position?
I could solve that
problem, potentially,
if I could solve Mine Sweeper
consistency by saying,
let's put a bomb there as part
of the partial information.
Is that consistent
with everything else?
So add a bomb to the
partial information.
Is that a consistent
configuration?
So if I could solve Mine
Sweeper consistency,
I could play Mine
Sweeper very well
by just testing which
are bombable positions.
If they're not, possible
to be a bomb there.
Actually click there
and get more information
and cook until done.
Now, maybe you could solve
Mine Sweeper in a different way
than using consistency.
But one way to solve it
would be consistency.
Question?
AUDIENCE: By consistency you
don't mean unique solution.
ERIK DEMAINE: I do not mean
unique solution, right.
Yeah.
So when you actually
want to solve the game,
you'd like there to
be a unique solution.
That's a problem we
will get to in a moment.
AUDIENCE: So a blank
board, unfilled information
is consistent.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yes.
Completely blank
board is consistent.
And it wouldn't be interesting.
As you're playing,
you imagine you've
gathered some information,
you add a bomb.
You want to say is
this consistent.
It says yes, like
you're in a blank board.
And you're like could
there be a bomb here.
Of course there could be.
Then that's not a safe move.
So if you could solve this,
you could identify safe moves.
Turns out you can't solve it,
so it doesn't directly help you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So there doesn't
always exist a safe move.
ERIK DEMAINE: There doesn't
AUDIENCE: What good
is it, kind of,
to know whether [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
I would say consistency
is the wrong problem
to solve for Mine Sweeper.
But it was the first
problem solved.
The gadgets are
relatively easy, which is
going to be fairly complicated.
And then we'll get to the
right problem for if you
wanted to solve the puzzle.
At this point it's an
interesting question.
You just want to know
is it consistent.
Did the computer cheat would
be one other perspective.
Or you could imagine some
adversarial Mine Sweeper
where you only decide the
bombs as the person is playing.
So here, just even telling
whether your opponent
is cheating is hard.
So that's another perspective.
Let's finish this proof.
We have a terminator, which
is actually a little bit
tricky here.
You can't just end with
ones because that would
force this guy to be a bomb.
So you end with
these threes, which
force-- these guys are already
bombs because of this picture,
and then exactly one of those
will still have to be a bomb.
And then we have a splitter.
It's a similar picture to Akari.
We have this two, which
forces exactly to two of these
to be present, and these
ones force alternation.
Now, I'm orienting these
arrows for the splitter
and defining true to be when
the pointy end of the arrow
is present.
So that means this is
actually a negated copy,
and these are unnegated copies.
But that's only from
the orientation.
This gadget's actually
symmetric, fourfold.
But if you put these
arrows in, which
you would do if you were
actually following a circuit,
their circuits are directed
acyclic graphs remember.
So this is negation, which is
good because it gives us a NOT,
it also gives us a split.
You can also end these
two things and get a turn.
So great, three gadgets in one.
So we already have NOT.
This is another way to do NOT.
And it's interesting here
because with Akari we
could stretch wires to any
length, any integer length
that's sufficiently long.
Here, we're forced in this
modulo three picture, normally.
But when we do something
like a negation
here we get kind of messed up.
We're no longer in the
same position modulo three.
We should be off
by one I believe.
So the idea is if you do
two negations in a row,
then you can end up
shifting by exactly two
and still have the same signal.
So you can see here
we have xx bar,
but down here we have it
shifted two positions over.
Or I guess it's more impressive
over here, so x bar x.
And normally this would repeat
in this kind of pattern.
So it actually shifted
by one position.
Good.
That's actually what I want.
So see the pattern here, here,
here, here, and shift by one.
Yeah, or two the
other direction.
OK, so that's good.
That lets me adjust
my wire length.
These are also often
called shift gadgets.
They just let you shift by one.
And whenever you have gadgets
that force certain modulo
constraints, just having
the ability to add one
is great because then you can
break all switch constraints.
You no longer have to
live in a mod three grid,
whatever, if you don't want to.
So this is important.
In general-- I'll add
it to the list here.
When you're dealing
with wires you
may need some kind
of shift gadget that
lets you fix parity issues,
or in this case, a mod three
parity.
OK, here is a more
complicated gadget,
which I will not go through.
It looks scary.
It's not actually
a ton going on.
It's a lot of gadgets
we've already seen.
It uses a slight-- I've
mentioned a turn gadget.
This is another
way to do a turn.
There's a few redundant
gadgets in this paper
because it's fun
to make gadgets,
so I want to have more.
So there's, for example,
just a turn gadget here.
There's a splitter here.
Another turn gadget.
This is reflectionally
symmetric around the x-axis.
There's basically
just a turn here,
so x is just getting copied
and negated into here.
z is getting copied
This is the output value,
which is getting copied around
into here.
And then a little bit of
magic happens here and here
to get these to interact
in the right way.
And it's essentially
just checking cases
to see that this computes
an AND of these two inputs.
But a little bit complicated.
AUDIENCE: Is coming
up with these gadgets
harder than checking them?
ERIK DEMAINE: Good question.
It's unclear.
Often when you're
designing things,
you have a lot more control,
and it could potentially
be easier to design hard
problems than to check them.
Because we know it's
NP-complete to check this,
in a certain sense.
I mean, of course, in this
case there's only four cases,
so it's not really that hard.
But yeah, when you're
designing things
you have in mind a certain
connectivity structure,
and then it's a matter
of getting things
to resolve in the grid and not
have things overlapping and so
on, which is a different
kind of constraint.
I might say it's a more fun one.
I would call designing these
puzzles meta puzzles, and to me
that's more fun.
But of course, I'm a
theoretical computer scientist.
That's why we're here.
Anyway, fun to
answer that question.
So here's a fun thing.
I hadn't seen this paper
before by Goldschlager in 1977.
They were worried about
p completeness, which
we haven't talked about yet.
But in particular, they
gave these two pictures.
This one we've seen.
If you have an x OR gadget,
you can construct a crossover.
Now, we don't have an
XOR gadget in this case,
but we have an AND
gadget or a NAND gadget.
This is the funny way of
writing NAND, NOT of an AND.
And if you have NAND gadgets
you can construct an XOR.
So if you plug this picture
into each of these three
pictures you get a kind of
ugly thing, but it's planar
and it implements a crossover.
Which means if you have NAND,
you get planarity for free.
So I'm going to call
this planar circuit SAT.
It's like catch, this, I
think is also a made-up term.
I haven't seen it
in the literature.
Because it's a little bit
vague what it could mean.
But let's say we're
given a planar directed
acyclic circuit.
And let's say all
gates are NAND.
Then this is NP-complete.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: Ah, right.
Sorry.
And at the end you
want it to be true.
Thank you.
So you have let's say the
sources are unconstrained.
So those represent
the variables.
And there's a sync,
which is set to one.
And we could say
there's just one sync.
So you have some
starting points.
Those are completely free
to choose true or false.
And then at the end
you have a sync.
I guess it just has one thing
probably coming into it.
Wouldn't make sense otherwise.
And we set this to be one.
So that's just like
satisfying formula,
but drawn as a Boolean
circuit, and it's planar.
Now, we're going to see
more versions of planar SAT
next class, but this one
as far as I know is newish.
It's essentially
argued in this paper.
Say, hey look--
this paper was not
talking about NP-completeness,
but the K paper says,
hey, we've got these
two things, so as long
as you have NAND you've
got crossovers for free.
So you don't have to worry about
planarity, which is good news.
So no crossover gadget needed.
There is one.
It's actually not that
hard in Mine Sweeper,
but it's nicer when you
don't have to do it.
Questions?
I guess I did talk
about termination.
We do need a true
terminator here
because we're doing circuit SAT.
That's really easy.
In fact, this would do it.
Just ending with all
ones means, in fact,
if there's zeroes out here, that
means this has to be a bomb.
And so that sets it to one.
So there's a true terminator
for Mine Sweeper consistency.
But as we've seen
in various ways,
Mine Sweeper consistency
is probably not
what we want to
actually play the game.
The algorithm I
gave you is one way
to think about playing the
game where you add a thing
and you check for consistency.
That's also a little
bit weird where
you're assuming that
the input is consistent,
and then you add
one bomb and you
want to see whether that
makes it inconsistent.
That's a special case
of this instance.
Maybe not as hard as
the general picture.
Everything was consistent
up until the moment you
added one new bomb information.
These pictures don't
look exactly like that.
Another thing I want to
point out in these gadgets
is let's say the number of x
and x bars is not the same.
Maybe this negation, this
equal numbers of x and x
bars over here, but
there's one extra x bar.
What that means is
local to this picture,
the number of bombs
that get used varies.
There's either one, two, three,
four bombs if you choose x,
or there's five bombs
if you choose x bar.
And one of the minor
things in Mine Sweeper
is that the total number of
bombs is given to you as input.
So that actually also
kind of messes things up.
Anyway, luckily, this
problem was solved.
It was actually independently
solved by multiple people.
It's claimed in Bob Hearn's
PhD thesis, though never
got fully written up.
And then it got published, so no
reason to write it up anymore.
So here is their proof.
Both this proof and
the previous one
appeared in Mathematical
Intelligencer.
So they draw the gadgets
slightly differently,
and so far everything
looks about the same.
They're not going to use a phase
changer in this form at least.
So they're going to draw
the wire gadget like this,
and the idea is that
you would copy it,
you get things mod
three, that will turn out
to be OK for them.
But what they really want
is that in each diagram
there are equal number
of x and x bars.
Why?
And also what are they proving?
So this is what they call the
Mine Sweeper inference problem.
But it's also what you might
just call Mine Sweeper.
I want to solve this puzzle.
What does it mean
to solve the puzzle?
Well, it means you're given
this partial information.
You want to know am I done?
Did I solve it?
Can I solve it?
Can I figure out where
all the bombs are?
This is like there
being a unique solution.
So I want to conclude
that, OK, I can figure out
where all the bombs are.
So can you figure
everything out?
So again, the reduction is from
something like circuit SAT.
It's going to be a reduction
from circuit unSAT.
Unsatisfiability.
So satisfiability you
want to set the variables
so that the outcome is true.
You might say, well, I could
try to set the variables
so the outcome is false.
That's the same problem.
That won't change.
Just put a NOT at the end.
Unsatisfiability means that you
cannot satisfy this formula.
There's no way to set
the variables to make
the output true.
There does not exist
choices for the x ANDs, such
that some f of xi's equals 1.
If we do some-- who knows,
this is called De Morgan?
Probably not.
Another fun fact is
NOT there exists,
NOT is the same thing as
for all or however you
want to write it.
So if we put this
negation over to here,
this turns into
universal quantifiers.
These are extensial
quantifiers to for alls.
So this is quite a
different problem.
3SAT is about do there exist
settings for these n variables
such that this comes
out to be true.
Now we're saying no matter
how you set the variables,
this comes out to be
true or false I guess.
But again, that doesn't matter.
You can just put the negation
inside f if you wanted to.
So the key difference
here is we switched
the quantify direction.
This is such a big difference
that this problem is not
NP-complete, unless
NP equals coNP.
This problem is coNP complete.
Recall coNP are the problems
where you can always given
no certificate.
Whenever the answer is no,
I can give you a short proof
that the answer is no.
How would I tell you that the
answer to this question is no?
I would give you a
satisfying assignment.
I'd give you xa to xn,
where f ends up being 1,
then you know this is not true.
It's very hard to
prove yes here.
I mean you might have to check
all possible exponentially many
assignments to the xi's.
Of course, we don't know
whether that's possible.
That's coNP completeness.
It's the same NP versus
p problem, but negated.
Cool.
So claim is Mine Sweeper
inference is coNP-complete.
And in general, the
proper statement
is Mine Sweeper
is coNP-complete.
Mine Sweeper consistency
is NP-complete,
but Mine Sweeper the game,
I want to solve the game,
is coNP-complete.
Cool?
This will be one of the few
cases where coNP arises for us.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Where does
coNP lie on this?
We don't know?
ERIK DEMAINE: In my
one-dimensional diagram,
you can think of NP and coNP
lying in the same space,
but maybe like in a
parallel universe.
I think.
People always draw
this picture, NP, coNP.
P is here, and this
is NP intersect coNP.
And some people think that's
the same thing as P. Who knows.
So there are parallel universes,
one about positive problems,
one about negative problems.
But in some sense,
equal complexity.
In this class we
think about reductions
as being one call reductions.
You take your
problem, you map it
so that the output when
you solve this new problem
has exactly the same solution
to the original problem.
If you instead think about
multi-call reductions
where you can make calls to an
oracle that solved the target
problem multiple times and
then do stuff with it--
you could, for example,
call that thing,
then negate the answer
and return that.
In that universe NP and
coNP become the same thing.
Or NP-completeness
and coNP-completeness,
which are about reductions,
become the same thing.
So that's the only
thing holding them apart
is that we're not allowed
to negate the answer.
So I view them as
almost the same,
but obviously they're different
and you have to distinguish one
from the other.
But in terms of difficulty
they're about the same.
The difference between NP
and coNP versus p space
is totally different, or x
time, or the other things
in my one-dimensional diagram.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Would p equals
NP imply p equals coNP?
ERIK DEMAINE: If p
equals NP, then I'm
pretty sure NP equals coNP,
because in polynomial time
you can do-- yeah. p is
closed under a complement,
because you can solve
the problem then negate.
So I should say NP and
coNP are different.
But NP-complete and
coNP-complete are very close,
let's say.
There's sort of dual-- for
every problem over here,
the corresponding problem
over here is like the hardest,
and they're sort of
symmetric or something.
All right.
Phew.
Back to Mine Sweeper.
So here is the
coNP-completeness.
We have wires just
like before, but I'm
drawing them differently.
Because part of the
issue here is we
are told how many
bombs there are,
and we don't want that
information to help us.
So we want every diagram
to have an equal number
of, say, x and x bars.
So if we set it with
x or set it with x
bar, we use exactly the
same number of bombs,
Which means knowing what
gadgets are glued together
we can just add up how
many bombs each one has.
That will be the total number
of bombs given to the puzzle.
And that shouldn't give
you any extra information
because all of these
pictures will have
equal number of x's and x bars.
So here we have wire,
terminator, and turn.
Pretty similar to
before, but now checking
that everything has equal
number of x's and x bars.
I think this turn,
for example-- no,
that one happens to be balanced.
Some of these gadgets
are not balanced.
This one almost certainly.
OK.
So in this case, they construct
a NOT gate and an OR gate.
And then they also
build a shifter.
This is a different
kind of shifter.
It still has width and multiple
of 3, but we're taking the wire
and shifting it
perpendicular by one unit.
With turns you can simulate
the other type of shifter,
but this turns out to be
the only one that they need.
So let's talk about
that first, let's say.
So if x is set by this two and
this bomb, this one is not set.
This four already
has three of them,
so it effectively becomes a one.
So then these two have to
be opposites from each.
This is sort of where
the shift happens.
And then because we have to
deal with these bombs that
are left over.
Let's put some more in.
And then this is five, so
there's already four here,
and so that forces
an alternation there.
So same idea, but
with some bombs
added in to fill the
space, let's say.
Got to do a one here, and
a one here, a one there.
This is a problem.
I can't put a one here.
That would force this
guy to be present.
So that's probably why
that bomb is there,
because we don't want to
have to say how many bombs
are adjacent to this corner.
With regular wires you
don't have corners.
Good.
But when you're doing a shift
you have sort of corner.
Same thing with the turn
gadget that we already saw.
OK.
I think NOT is also
pretty intelligible,
but it's fairly complicated.
It essentially involves making
another copy of the signal
just so we get an equal
number of x's and x bars.
Because we saw in the previous
reduction with a NOT gate,
we had this one isolated guy.
That would be like this one.
And so if you just have
this picture, yeah,
it would negate things.
And again, this is
designed to be mod three,
so there's three, six-- that's
hard to do-- nine, 12, 15.
So things are nicely aligned
on the mod three boundary,
but they end up with
these three dudes.
They end up flipping the signal.
Here's x, here's also x,
which is like the reverse
because it's on the left.
But this would have an unequal
number of x's and x bars.
There's too many
x's in this row.
So we end up splitting off a
negated copy here, basically,
to balance things out.
And now if you count
all the x's and x bars
they should be equal.
Cool.
And then they build an OR gate.
So it's again, looks
fairly complicated.
Probably pretty
simple in essence,
but I don't feel like
checking all those cases.
What is annoying is that this
thing is not mod three aligned.
Mod three aligned
would be here or here,
with the output always
in the middle finger.
But instead it's here.
And so they used the
shift gadget over here
to offset that by
one, and similarly
in all three pictures.
And then you get an OR
gate with proper alignment.
Everything works
out in mod three.
OK.
Cool.
So we have NOT and we have
OR, therefore we have NOR,
and therefore we can build
any logical gate we want.
An so we have turns, we
have shifts that we need,
we have NOT, we have--
did we do split?
I think we did split
on the previous-- nope,
we didn't do split.
OK, then let's do split.
So we need to copy our wires.
This is a more complicated
version of the previous split.
Again, with an extra
thing thrown in.
Like this is not needed.
You don't have to put this here,
but it adds an extra x bar.
So there's actually
two of those things.
And so together that offsets
all the extra x copies
that are on the inside.
And so that forces, again,
equal number of bombs,
whether it's x or x bar chosen.
So we can just
count how many bombs
are needed in this picture.
Cool.
This is, again, a
symmetric version.
So if you're thinking of,
let's say, this as the input,
and these two as the output,
than negation happened.
So if you don't want
negation to happen,
just put a big NOT gate there.
And in this case they
give a crossover gadget.
In particular
because it's not that
hard to give a crossover gadget,
but it's also not necessary.
So you could do
crossover explicitly,
but in fact, I just looked
on Wikipedia earlier today.
We already know that planar
circuit SAT with NAND gates
is hard.
So can we build NAND?
And so I looked up in Wikipedia,
how you build NAND out of NORs.
And the answer is this.
And that's planar.
So we're done.
You take this picture, you plug
it into each of these guys.
And you take that
picture and you plug it
into each of these guys.
Make sure to preserve
planarity all the way through.
It does.
And then from-- I should know
that's you construct NAND out
of NOR.
It's exactly from De Morgan law,
because this is just negation.
So cool thing is all
these constructions
preserve planarity
which means we
can add to our definition
of planar circuit SAT.
All gates are NAND
or all gates are NOR.
This is nice because when you're
solving next p set or whatever,
you can just take
planar circuit SAT,
if you happen to construct
a NAND gate you're done.
If you happen to construct
an OR gate you're done.
No crossover needed.
You'll still need turns,
and maybe a shift,
and maybe a terminator.
You won't need NOT if
you build NAND or NOR.
You'll need a split, but you
don't need a crossover anymore.
This is cool.
As far as I know a new result,
but I mean obviously implicit
in all of these things.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you know if there's
any sub-problem, I guess,
is that where you don't
have universal gates
and you can't be planar
and get it so hard?
So maybe you can--
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh, interesting.
AUDIENCE: You can
split wires and you
have a variable that has the
negation of it coming out,
but that's all you can do.
No other NOT gates.
ERIK DEMAINE: My guess is
that all such problems are
polynomially solvable,
but maybe that's something
we could think about.
Certainly plausible
that you don't
need to be able to construct
all Boolean formulas in order
to be hard.
But my vague sense/experience
playing around
with weird other
gates, most of them
are all equivalent to
splits if they're not
universal-- something
like a split.
Maybe with some like
five operand operator,
you could do something cool.
But usually they degenerate
to other split-like things
or clause-like things.
But if you don't have both, you
don't get enough to be hard.
We should prove a
theorem like that,
but I would guess that you
need something like this.
Now these are not the
only universal gate sets.
I think in a moment I will
have a-- if you are curious
about more of what
universal gate sets are,
these are usually
called functionally
complete or functional
completeness.
If you look at
that on Wikipedia,
this is an excerpt
from Wikipedia,
you see NAND and NOR are
the only, among arity two
operators, so you have
two inputs, one output.
NAND and NOR are
the only things that
by themselves are universal.
But once you allow two different
gates you can do other things.
So these are
particularly interesting.
This is false I think.
It's called [INAUDIBLE], and
this is called top, it's true.
And so these are slightly
unusual ways for me
to think about writing them.
Here we have, of
course, AND and NOT.
But this is right
implication, which
is like not the left
thing or the right thing.
We talked about
that in the past.
That by itself is not
enough, because you can just
follow implication chains.
But if you also have
false, that is universal.
So that's kind of funny.
And this is XOR I think.
XOR is the same as saying that
the two things are different.
And this is XNOR.
So those by themselves
are not universal,
but if you have some other
kind of one-way implication,
then that gives you
any logical formulas.
Now, whether these in the planar
version are hard, I don't know.
But I know that Ds in the
planar version are hard.
OK, back to Mine Sweeper.
They drew a picture of how
everything fits together,
so it's maybe nice to
have the big picture.
But let's in particular
think about what the decision
question is and make sure--
I mean I claim this is coNP
and then we're doing unSATs, but
we should actually check that.
At this point we've just
simulated a circuit.
We haven't thought about what
we're trying to solve overall.
Now, we want to know whether
we can derive everything.
So we compute our formula
and then the output is here.
And at this point
there's just a terminal
there saying I don't
know what it is.
Different from the
previous proof.
The previous proof said that
should be one at the end,
and then you have to figure
out how to fill in the things.
Now we're saying, I
don't know what's there.
Can you figure out what's there?
And if it's the case
that no matter how
you set the variables
you always get false,
then you know what
this wire looks like.
You know that it's false.
And in fact, you can
figure out everything.
If you know what
all the XI's are
you can just run
through the circuit.
So you can figure out
the entire diagram.
But in general, just
asking the question,
can I figure out this square?
Is there a bomb or not?
In order for there
not to be a bomb,
you would have to
solve this problem.
You need to determine
that no matter
how you set the things
you end up with a zero.
Or the adjacent position
it would be the opposite.
So conversely, what I
really care about-- that
was the wrong direction.
I'm given a circuit
unSAT instance.
I want to turn it into
a Mine Sweeper instance.
So I do that, and then the
question is-- get this right--
can you derive whether there
is a bomb in this square?
Can you determine that there
must be a bomb in this square,
for example?
That would be a slightly
cleaner version.
And that will be true, if and
only if no matter what you do,
there's a bomb in that square.
Which is like saying
no matter what you do,
this formula comes out to zero.
So any kind of inference
question like that
is going to require you
to solve this problem,
or rather, this
problem can be reduced
to any inference
problem like that.
It's easy to get backwards here,
so hope I got it all right.
And that's coNP completeness.
Reductions look
the same for coNP.
We just start with
different problems.
Cool.
So that was Mine Sweeper
and functional completeness.
I have one more-- well,
sort of two more proofs.
Only one that I will talk
about in detail for Candy Crush
and soon enough, Bejeweled.
But let's think about Candy
Crush is the modern version.
I'm guessing you've all
played, but in case not,
please don't play.
It's very addictive.
But on the slides
we're allowed to.
So you have a grid of
colors, colored candies.
And a move in this game
is to take two candies
and switch their order.
I guess in this picture
I did these two.
If you switch these two
you get this picture.
And the mechanics of the
game, the physics or whatever,
is whenever you have
three or more candies
of the same color in a row
or column, or in a row,
then they disappear.
And anything above them falls.
So like this red
candy ends up there.
In this case, there were
no more candies above.
In the real game usually there's
always more candies above.
But if we're in a small game
this won't-- if we're in a big
game and looking
at a small window,
we know everything
about what will fall.
AUDIENCE: Do you need to
make them fall or do they
automatically fall
once you get--
ERIK DEMAINE: They
automatically fall.
Yeah, so they are
forced to fall.
It's all I get to
do is make this move
and then stuff happens.
So I make this move
and then anything
that-- any three in a
rows or more disappear.
And then if that makes
more three in a rows
they will disappear and so on.
And my hands are
off at that point.
Once the chain
reactions are finished--
not all games work this
way, but Candy Crush
happens to work this way.
Once these things are finished,
then I can do another exchange.
And when I do an exchange
I must make three in a row.
I can't just swap
these two guys.
It's not interesting.
AUDIENCE: What if it's like a
T pattern or like non-linear?
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, OK.
In this picture
we'll never have Ts.
It will always be three in a
row, and never a four in a row.
With four in a row, magical
striped candies happen
and you don't want to know.
So potentially you can get up to
five in a row with these rows,
but in these reductions
that won't happen.
So we don't care what
the rules say there.
We're only going to
get three in a rows.
There is a weird
catch in this proof.
I'm going to mention two proofs
from 2014, so all very recent.
I guess the game isn't that old.
And in this proof we're going
to assume if-- in general, there
may be multiple three
in a rows at once.
And the proof is going to assume
that they are resolved bottom
to top, so you do the
bottom-most one first, things
fall, then you do the next one,
things fall, do the next one,
things fall.
That's not how the
actual game works.
In the game, they all
disappear simultaneously
and then stuff falls.
OK, but ignore that
for the moment.
The next proof will
change the model.
OK, this is a much easier
one to think about and draw
the pictures.
So in that model, here's
a variable gadget.
The starting point's the
same, picture top and bottom.
And the idea is
either you exchange
these two to make
three, or you exchange
these two to make three.
And the consequence is either
the right column falls by three
or the middle column
falls by three.
And that's all you can
do local to this gadget.
So that's easy.
Things are going to get messier.
OK, so you have this picture,
variable gadget for XI.
Above it I'm going to make
one of these two gadgets.
Actually, both of them,
but one at a time.
So in fact, it will
actually look kind
of like this, stacked on
top of the variable which
is down here.
So variables down here.
Either the center column falls
or the right column falls.
Now, the idea is this is
going to eventually connect
to a clause, and this
variable-- I should
say this is not for
circuit SAT, this
is from 3SAT-- regular old 3SAT.
So that variable
appears in a clause
either in positive
form or negative form.
Positive, use this gadget.
Negative, use this gadget.
So in the positive case,
if this falls by three
we get this picture, and
then these disappear,
and so this guy falls one more.
And the idea is that's going
to trigger something off
to the right.
That will be next slide.
That will be the wire gadget.
If the center column fell by
three, nothing would happen.
The purples-- so I
should mention how
these gadgets are constructed.
There's a four color sort
of checkerboard pattern
in odd rows.
It's alternating orange,
green, orange, green.
In even rows it's alternating
red, yellow, red, yellow.
And then in a few places we're
going to put the purple ones,
because purple's best.
And all the action is going
to be in the purple candies.
These guys are just out
there-- and the real game
has six colors.
We're only using five of them.
So cool.
These guys are
just sort of filler
to make sure nothing
else happens.
But still things fall vertically
in a nice controlled way.
OK, so if these fall
by three, the purples
don't align so nothing happens.
In this case, if the
center one falls by three
we get alignment, and
that falls by one.
So great.
Also note, these gadgets
stack somewhat nicely.
In that other than this
three gap-- in reality,
more candies will fill in here.
I drew it this way
so you could see how
much the columns actually fall.
Remember, this all sort
of happens in one move.
So this falls, these clear,
then this will clear,
and stuff happens.
It's annoying.
So, so far everything's
good because each of these
has fallen by one in addition
to the original three.
But in this case, this
follows by an extra one,
and I think you need to
add an extra candy here.
I'm a little unclear in the
details on how to do that.
It's mentioned in the
paper, but without details.
Anyway, in the end we
will have a bunch of these
stacked on top of each other.
Each time the variable
occurs in various clauses
we're going to
have some positive
and some negative ones.
And we want the same variable
trigger-- ah, that's right.
There will be-- well, OK.
Yeah.
I'm going to leave it like that.
So at this point we have
a purple thing triggering
something to the right.
So now I'm going to show
you how that part works.
This is the wire.
So the wire itself is like this.
And the idea is that when
there's a purple one here,
a chain reaction happens.
And it happens in this way.
As soon as there's a purple
candy here, this clears,
which makes these
two fall by one,
which clears that, which
makes this fall by one,
and triggers the next thing.
This one, some stacking happens.
Let's see.
So overall, I think this one
is actually better behaved.
This falls by one
here and then two.
So overall these
columns fell by two.
This column has
fallen so far by one,
but it's about to
fall by a second one,
because this will always
trigger something.
And so these do stack
nicely, because you always
clear exactly two columns.
The worry is that the gadget
above it will be skewed.
Let me give you one
more gadget, then
I'll tell you-- no,
actually, I think
at this point I should tell
you how things fit together,
which is this picture.
So we have variables down
here in the lower left.
Then let's worry about
one thing at a time.
These are the
connection gadgets.
I don't think I
told you their name.
But they are your
connector gadgets.
This is making a 90 degree turn.
From the falling
action we're going
to get a purple in a
particular position, which
causes rightward motion.
And then the wires that you
saw basically go in some angle
off to the right.
I want these all to
be non-intersecting.
And there's sort of two of them.
There's going to be the true
case and the false case.
And then way over
here somewhere,
we're going to have a clause
where these wires all attach.
And then above it
we're going to have
a reward where you get tons
of points, and et cetera.
So let me tell you
what happens next.
It's a fun way to
draw the picture.
So above these we'll have
some other connections.
I should not do it
in the same pattern.
I should not do it like that.
Yeah, sure.
Connection, connection.
OK, again, diagonal lines.
Great.
Not quite diagonal.
It's an angle.
We have a clause.
Everything connects up.
Above the clause is a reward.
And then I move boards,
and that's the picture.
And above the
variables, we just keep
adding more connections
connected to some clauses.
And there's not just three
variables, of course.
There's n variables down here,
and we use some, three of them,
and then connect
that off to a clause.
And they're all just stacked--
I happen to draw the clauses
one on top of the other.
That shouldn't happen.
So there's some
extra space here.
This is more over to the right.
So that none of them will
interact with each other.
That's the goal.
Except there's some issues,
like notice this wire gadget,
notice dual rail logic.
Either this is active
or this is active.
And we hope that
not both of them
are active, although that
can actually happen here.
I'll get to that.
So when this activates,
notice this goes
on top of a variable gadget.
Now, a wire by itself
is kind of good.
We've seen it removes two
things from every spot.
So things don't shift too much.
And furthermore, we should
hope that either this activates
or this activates.
So this will shift by
a consistent amount
in either case.
But the wire may get messed up
because the variable actually
removes three things
from one of the columns.
So we need a better wire
gadget, which looks like this.
This is a super wire gadget.
It's really cool.
It works no matter how
you use it, kind of.
So this is what it
looks like in general.
And this is regular use.
So as before, if
we trigger this,
then this triggers, and this guy
falls by one, just like before.
But now also, if there's
a variable down here
and this column falls
by three-- or sorry.
If this column falls by
three, so the same picture,
the things fell by three,
still everything works out.
These two fall.
These two fall but they
meet a different dude.
But there were a bunch of guys
to meet up with, so it's fine.
And I clearly drew the
output in the wrong place.
The output should
be here I think.
Yeah.
So in this picture
the output was here,
also it shifted by one.
In this picture the output
is here, not up there.
So in both cases it triggers.
And finally if the middle
column fell by three
before this gadget
activated, then this,
again, triggers this time
with this guy being different.
Instead of this one matching,
this one's matching.
That still triggers these guys
and this is still the output.
So this is a
different wire gadget
that works in three
different scenarios,
depending on what
happened below it.
So that's good news.
That lets us do
this type of wire.
And in general, we're going
to have a chain reaction all
the way down here until we
get to the clause from bottom
to top.
And this we'll resolve.
And let me show you the clause.
I think details are
a little bit messy.
There's a little
locking mechanism here.
But basically the idea is
all of these things come
in, x1, x1 bar, x2, x2 bar.
All of the half
wires or semi-wires.
And so we expect one
of these to activate.
Maybe you don't do that,
but that would be weird,
and you won't end up
satisfying the clause.
So if this one activates, then
these align, and you're happy.
In general, if you can
get this column to fall,
you're going to be happy,
because above this thing is
this reward gadget.
And if this column falls by
one, you get a million points.
And every clause has its own
reward of a million points,
and million here is like
n squared or something.
So you really want to get these.
And the only way to do it
is to satisfy the clauses.
The only way to
get all the point
is satisfy all the clauses.
Now, the goal in this
game, I didn't mention,
is to maximize the number
of points you can get
for a given number of moves.
Usually in Candy Crush you
have a limited number of moves.
So the idea is you're just going
to have enough moves to set
each of the variables right.
If you end up setting one
of the wires directly--
you can trigger any wire
by doing a little flip.
You can say I'll
trigger this one wire.
But that will satisfy,
at most, one clause.
Whereas if you do
it on a variable,
you're going to satisfy
a bunch of clauses,
and that's clearly better.
So that's a bit of an
argument you need to make.
It doesn't help enough.
You could even set this wire
and this wire, an xy or an x bar
wire.
But the claim is
that will never buy
you as much as setting
an entire variable,
and here's the reason why.
I drew this picture
simply to say
for every clause we're going
to have this picture connected
to some variables.
In fact, every time
you have a clause,
you make a million
copies of the clause.
And million is like n.
So that it's really
worth setting the var--
every variable appears
in millions of clauses.
So you really want
to set the variables.
If you just satisfy
one measly clause
and get one measly million
points, it's not worth it.
But if you can get a million
times a million points, whoa,
a trillion points.
So that's why you should
only set variables, not
set wires directly.
OK.
I think I have roughly
covered this proof, except I
didn't go up the chain.
Here, setting x1 bar doesn't
do much except setting one
or the other of these ends up
shifting all of these things
by one, which ends of
clearing this, which shifts
all of these columns by one.
And basically things look
really spread out here,
but as you work
your way up, they're
coming more and
more into alignment.
The idea is as long as things
resolve from bottom to top,
you-- it doesn't-- then first
you figure out whether x1
satisfies the clause.
If it doesn't, it
sets things up for x2.
And then maybe x2
satisfies the clause.
If it doesn't, it sets
things up for x3 here.
They're spread out even more.
But by the time you've
done these things below,
that thing will be ready.
So that was the first proof.
The second proof--
sorry, before interlude.
Candy Crush is based
on a variety of games.
Most famous is Bejeweled,
but there is a long history
of-- even Tetris is in there.
There's a long history
of match three games.
And pretty much all of
these are NP-complete.
I don't know the
details of all of them,
but there's this paper by three
authors a little bit later
in the year that proves
basically all of these games
are NP-complete, even when
you're not given a move limit.
So this is interesting.
And Bejeweled, the goal is
just to maximize your score.
You don't necessarily have a
limit on the number of moves,
unlike Candy Crush.
And also in some levels
candy Crush is like that.
So here it was very crucial
that we only had enough moves
to trigger all the variables.
We didn't want to be
able to do other things.
So here's a different
proof, and I'm just
going to give the high
level picture, basically.
This is cool, because
even just figuring out
whether you get this one
gem, this one candy is hard.
In order to do so,
you have to line up
all of these things
for each clause.
And here's the reduction
from exactly one of 3SAT.
So only if exactly
one of the variables
get set correctly does this
shift to the right level,
and only when all of these are
shifted to the right level can
you trigger this wire to go all
the way here and get that guy.
And it's the only
way to get that guy.
You can't do it directly.
It can only be triggered
from the left-hand side.
And there's also a
sequencer over here,
which forces all
of the variables
to get set before this happens.
So it's a little tricky,
because you don't want it to be,
you could say half of them,
and then trigger this,
and then things happen to
align in a cheating way.
The details are complicated,
but they actually
implemented their reduction.
So this is it.
Now, as it says here, there are
4,000 rows above and 2,000 rows
below.
So it's a large construction.
And this is for this formula.
[LAUGHTER]
I can clean it up a little
bit, remove the-- again,
there's a background
checkerboard pattern here.
So if I generate instance then
things are little bit cleaner.
And I think highlighted in red
are the moves you can make.
So here's the first variable.
You could either-- let's
do the simple one first--
move this guy with this one, and
then trigger, trigger, trigger.
All this happens without
you able to do anything.
And that will move
some stuff up top.
Or we can move this one
here, and then this is fun.
The variable goes
down and it just
keeps-- it goes down, basically,
to where the x1 bar is,
down here, and then it triggers
that guy, and maybe that guy
also.
And that one.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
Just lots of stuff happens.
Anyway, eventually
we'll get down to x2
and we'll be able to set
it one way or the other.
So the details are obviously
a little bit complicated,
but clearly they've
been explicitly
worked out because they can
even play the game, which
is pretty awesome.
Anyway, and they also
have the greatest URL,
candycrush.isnphard.com.
We should try to get other
things not as nphard.com.
That is Candy
Crush and Bejeweled
and all of its
friends are NP hard.
That's it, unless
there are questions.
So we've just started to
scratch the surface on the idea
that planar graphs are
hard, and next class we'll
see planar versions of
3SAT and one and 3SAT.
If we weren't using here, this
is using a non-planar thing.
So that helps with a lot
of proofs, especially
ones that happen in the plane.
So we've seen it with
planar circuit SAT.
But next we'll do planar and
3SAT, planar one and 3SAT,
planar not all equal SAT,
those kinds of things.
And again, be able to avoid
crossovers, which is nice.
Cool.